so this is the result of the poll the
North East Somerset constituency IJ fara
being the deputy actin returning officer
with UK Parliament to general election
for the North East Somerset constituency
from the simple may 2015 do here my cam
notice that the number of votes cast for
each candidate in this election was as
follows flavor earning UK 6150
voiced Katie Green Party 2,800 and
Labour Party 12,000 694 pal Spira
Liberal Democrats 4029 and resmoke Jacob
a Conservative Party candidates 25,000
for
three ballot papers were rejected and I
therefore declare the same Jacob Riis
log is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for the North East Somerset
constituency the turnout for North East
Somerset was seventy three point eight
seven percent
rosy-fingered toward is I think
approaching outside but the counties is
all done and it's my duty of pressure to
thank everybody who's been involved
everybody in ensuring that it's been run
properly and lawfully and we've got a
result but also to thank the other
counties for their participation in the
hustings and their commitment to making
sure our democracy runs properly in the
good spirit in which they have done it I
will confess that Ernie and I agreed
rather too often on the hustings about
various matters which may tell you
something about our respective positions
the candidates have made a huge
contribution to the process I want also
thank IOT who have been family as my
agent Margaret Brewer and my tireless
campaign manager who's told me I'm not
allowed to thankings I will Owen Reese I
think my seven-year-old who delivered a
leaflet and I did buy my ten phone as
has been a real team effort so thank you
to everybody who has been involved from
a broader political point of view I
think it's a very interesting night that
we see what has happened in Scotland and
we should be concerned about that for
the point of view of our nation as a
union which I think manages to survive
the shock of the loss of say many
unionist candidates in Scotland I think
that is a problem but as a conservative
tonight I'm celebrating that in
if we will have a conservative
government that we will continue the
policies of ensuring that the economy is
set on the right track that we will have
a referendum on our membership with the
European Union and some people may even
wave to me and then we will have how
strong and clear government at a time of
great uncertainty and as always there's
always easier to say when one party is
doing well but it's true even in Reverse
situations the British people have said
their good sense when faced with a clear
choice and they have decided that they
want a clear decision
not another vexed and uncertain one so I
think it's a very good night thank
everybody who stays so late in the early
morning you are hardy souls indeed as I
know the good people of North East
Somerset always off it more very much